over a decade ago our next guest spent
some time singing alongside her family
in Central Park then she was discovered
by Jay-Z never heard of him uh she's
gone on to become a Grammy winning
songwriter and critically acclaimed
singer now performing I don't have to
pretend off her latest album Glory hour
give it up for victory
[Applause]
[Music]
everybody
near I
know they do you
hear me my
eyes crying
tears my
heart in
humility please my Cas for my
complaint here at the
altar why should I carry this
weight why should I
suffer when I have a savior who
intimately
cares for my
s yes I have a savior who came to bear
this
grief in my
place
I don't have to pretend like
everything's
okay that's not what Jesus me when he
said to have
F if you see me crying
I'm being true instead of
lying about what I'm going
through I'm trusting God to heal my
every
word and I know he
will he makes all things
[Music]
new All Things
New All Things New
I don't have to
pretend like everything so
[Applause]
okay that's not what Jesus meant when he
said to have
[Music]
Fai if you see me
crying
I'm being true instead of
lying about what I'm going
through I'm trusting God to heal my
every
word and I know he
will he
makes
things I trust you
to
make
[Music]
all oh my gosh once more put your hands
together for victory y'all pick up her
new album Glory hour wherever you get
your music Beautiful cover we'll be
right back with what I'm
[Music]
likeing
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home